thank you
hey everybody
uh thanks for coming out tonight so
tonight i'm going to be talking about
influx db
uh which is an open source distributed
time series database uh that me and a
couple other guys built
first in case you didn't read my bio
i'll tell you a little bit about me so
you know who i am
i'm the co-founder and ceo of a company
called airplane we did y combinator
earlier this year
i'm the founder and organizer of the new
york city machine learning meetup i'm
the author of a book called service
service oriented design with ruby and
rails
um and as jared mentioned i'm the series
editor for addison wesley's data and
analytics series which jared's book is
actually under so
um
okay so
most of you probably already know this
but
uh i just wanted to get into what a time
series is and why
why anybody would be interested in doing
stuff with time series
so
the obvious one is for metrics right so
this could be like a graph of like
response times or some other things or
whatever like in your systems that you
run
and of course we're in new york so i
would be remiss if i didn't mention you
know stock prices and stuff like that
uh then there's user facing analytics
right you're looking at like
page views over time or whatever
but i would say
this is also a time series so this is
like a snippet of a log file from apache
and this actually is like you could
probably construct like
40 different time series out of this
right
number of gets per whatever per minute
uh 200 responses 401s different user ids
different pages that are being hit
i would say this is also a time series
too so this is like a search i did a
couple of days ago on twitter
of mentions of influx db and that's
something that i would actually like to
visualize as the time series is number
of mentions like per day
of this project
so but i'm really for us like working
with time series with this it's not just
about like
a time series name a time stamp and a
value uh we want to have a more complex
data model that allows for tracking
events so in this case we could be
talking about measurements like
measuring you know your cpu load or
whatever
but it could be exceptions that are
occurring in your application it could
be page views user actions commits from
develop developers in the project
deploys that you're doing
all these things are
things that happen in time that you
might care about summarizing or
visualizing or analyzing
so and that's
all this kind of falls roughly under the
umbrella of analytics so i i view
analytics as like these four different
tiers right there's operations analytics
there's developer analytics user
analytics for product managers and then
finally like business analytics for the
actual business owners
and again like i said there you want to
ask questions about this data so that
you can either visualize it summarize it
or analyze it or do things
so
this this is actually a summarization
right so it says the the volume here was
like 19 million
19 million trades or something like that
uh so obviously like you don't have that
many pixels to represent the data so
you're summarizing what the price was
over this time period
and this is also a summarization
if it's
you know a cpu load that you're
measuring say you take that measurement
once every sec every 10 seconds that's
just a summarization of the actual cpu
load you're not tracking it as it
changes
so
uh
one one thing that
some people have asked me about is like
wait a second
a time series database to me
just sounds like a regular database but
with a timestamp column and you order by
that
and that's true
but there are some things that i think
make
a time series database a little special
and a reason why you'd want to build a
database specifically for this kind of
data as opposed to just using postgres
or mysql or whatever
so the most obvious one is
you can have potentially billions of
data points
uh even for people who don't necessarily
have like insane amounts of user traffic
like you know facebook level or whatever
it's still really easy to take enough
measurements across enough things that
you generate a lot of data really
quickly
so you want the ability to scale
horizontally
but
i would argue even for people who have
small to medium-sized data and honestly
that's the vast majority of people like
if you think you have a big data problem
you probably don't you just need to
optimize a bit um
but
there's
i mean there are still advantages for
people who just run this on a single
node right uh
one of our design goals is we wanted
something that was http native
and what that means is like it makes it
so that we can have an easy api for
people to build tooling around
we wanted tools that were included that
made it easy to do down sampling and
summarizing of the data so we didn't
have to like a lot of times when people
are working with time series data
they'll have like some other process
running
where it'll either
monitor the data in real time as it
comes in and then output like down
samples and summarizations or they'll do
it in batch like if you're doing big
data they'll do like a mapreduce job
once an hour or once a day to build
these these summarizations and it's kind
of a pain to have to like always write
that code to do that thing
the other thing is we wanted it to be
efficient and easy to automatically
clear out all data so some data you want
to keep it around all the time like a
lot of times with some
some like exception data or whatever
some user level data you want to keep it
around all the time
but a lot of this stuff
you know you really don't care about it
after it's more than like a week or two
weeks old you really just want the
summaries and then the raw data the high
precision data like you know
again i keep coming back to cpu but like
what your cpu was at in 10 second
intervals like
after two weeks you really just care
about the general trends
finally we wanted something where we
could process and monitor the data uh in
real time as it comes in without having
to
write a separate like thing that runs on
its own that we have to monitor and deal
with we wanted a data store that would
make that easy so basically like
storm except for storm is not easy
because then you have to have all this
other crap running
um
so finally when i'm looking at like
visually and summarizing stuff we're
talking about graphs and dashboards and
you're looking at
different
levels of precision different levels of
granularity that you're summarizing on
for data collection
there are a lot of different options and
i think
having a standard api so that you can
build on tools for like using statsd
which is a thing that'll do
summarizations of like you can just feed
it a ton of data points it'll calculate
like either counts or percentiles and
stuff for you on whatever arbitrary
interval you set it to like 10 seconds
or a minute or whatever
uh collective which is for uh collecting
local data on across your servers
heka is an interesting project
by mozilla it's written in go it's for
um there's processing log files and
stuff like that and some other things
l2met is another project that's written
in go and it's built for parsing log
files and pulling metrics out of them
and then of course you have all these
other things like libraries
integrations with frameworks
and integrations with other third
parties
so
the they're obviously like this isn't a
new problem like people have been
working with this for a while they're
existing tools
uh there's rd tool which is like pretty
old-school uh but which is basically
like a round-robin database it's
a limited data model because you can't
write in like raw event data it's really
just like time stamps and metrics and
and values uh and it's not distributed
uh graphite uh which is fairly popular
is also not distributed and has that
same like limitation on the data model
open tsdb
they they have a more complex api so you
can actually write like dimensions or
like key value pairs for your data
points um
but
it's basically just a bunch of web
services on top of hbase so if you want
to run opentsdb you've got to run a
hadoop cluster an hbase and you have to
have these web services running and
there are some limitations on
the
on the api that make it so there are
some queries you just can't do so if you
want to do those queries you'd have to
have other code to make those
computations for you
and then the last problem with open tsb
well
last one i'm going to mention
is it has hotspots so
all of the data for a single time series
goes to
the same node so even if you have a
hadoop cluster that's like 500 boxes if
you're writing a lot of data to a single
time series as you would do would say
like
tracking page views
uh
it's only gonna it's all gonna it's
gonna shard all of that data to a single
node
um kairos which is essentially opentsdb
but ported to use cassandra as the back
end so again it has a problem where you
have to run a cassandra cluster
i'm not sure how the underlying
implementation is but if they're using
rows only rows for to represent time
series then they would also have a
hotspot of because rose and cassandra
shard to a single node
so
we felt that there was something missing
in the
in the set of existing tools
we wanted something where we could send
raw metrics like raw telemetry data but
also send like events and stuff that you
would use for like user analytics
so we created uh
influx db
um
so
does anybody have any idea what the logo
means or what it is
it does it does it does have some sort
of meaning
all right
this was going to be the hint
so
the flux capacitor from uh back to the
future and we figured like it's a time
series database we can't really take you
back in time but we can give you a
glimpse at the past
i don't know
so yeah it's a cluster of flux
capacitors
uh it's like the tagline we're thinking
of
still work in progress
uh okay so let's get let's get to the
the api and the internals
so it's written in go
and it uses a level db for the
underlying data storage level db is an
embedded database that was written at
google uh it's written in c plus plus it
was written by jeff dean by a bunch of
people but primarily jeff dean and
sanjay gemwat who are like the guys at
google that are responsible for doing
all their hardcore
infrastructure stuff that they built
early on like they basically built
mapreduce and all this other stuff
so
it's pretty good but that may change we
may change it because of
certain requirements that we have
particularly with the deleting large
ranges of data
regularly it's not it doesn't have
something built in for that
uh
so it's a self-contained binary we
really wanted something that had no
other dependencies like a lot of people
i've built multiple like time series
databases uh
at different places and essentially it's
always like a web service with some
back-end data store like cassandra or
hbase some people use redis or they use
[ __ ] or just like postgres or mysql
but we we wanted a system where
you could just deploy the binary on a
cluster of machines and not have
anything else you had to manage or deal
with
it has no external dependencies
so
part of this talk is vaporware uh
i said well so we're saying it's a
distributed time series database but the
truth is
we're still working on the distributed
code that'll be ready in december right
now
it's very much a project that's in
development mode like the api is there
and you can play around with it but we
haven't blessed any builds for
production use yet that will be by the
end of the year
so
what do i mean when i say like http
native i mean that you can read and
write data from via http you can manage
the cluster from http now it doesn't
mean http only it just means
the very first protocol that we support
is that because we figured it'd be
easiest to use and the other thing is we
wanted
a security model that made it so that
you could read and write data directly
from the browser so
if you're
if you're building like a system that
has user user facing analytics and you
have like data collection happening
and you have like different users
looking at different things you don't
want them to be able to see each other's
data and if you're going to access the
database directly from
the browser you need to make sure that
there's a security model in place that
will let you do that i mean our goal
there was
people shouldn't have to write extra
server-side code to get this thing up
and running and build custom analytics
on top of it
so here's how data is organized in the
system you have databases which is just
like you know a database in a relational
database
uh you have time series which you can
view as kind of like tables the
difference is you don't actually have to
create them ahead of time the second you
write to a time series it
it comes into existence like you don't
have to declare it
and then there are points or events
uh it's the same thing those two words
are pretty much interchangeable for me
which you can look at as kind of being
like rows but again it's schema-less
so
i'll cover what that looks like in a
second
so for security there are three
different types of users there's cluster
administrators who can create databases
and manage all user accounts they're
database admins
who can
manage the user accounts for a given for
the given database there that they're an
administrator of and then there are
database users and there are two
different levels of permissioning
there's permissioning on the reads and
permissioning on the rights
and with both of these you can say like
okay they can only read or write to
this particular series
and you can also say
it for reads like
any query you do against this series has
to have this additional like where
clause attached to it so for example if
you're tracking events and you have like
a customer id is something that you're
tracking and you have different
customers logging into this this front
end you can say like okay for this
person they can only issue a query with
customer id equals 23 so they can't see
anybody else's data
and the same thing for rights you can
issue them specific user accounts for
doing writes where you say like
any rights to this particular time
series have to include this additional
column and value
so getting set up
we have uh
at play.influxdb.org just like a sandbox
that you can go
create a database really quick and start
reading and writing data like within a
couple of seconds
uh if you're on os x you can install it
through homebrew there was a problem
with this earlier that they may or may
not have fixed by now uh so you may have
to install the dependencies before doing
that uh they're on the readme on the
github page uh or ubuntu or red hat
packages
just go to influxdb.org slash download
to see all that stuff
so
i have examples
in a second
i have examples but uh
sadly there's no r
we don't have an r library
but
there are http api docs
here at influxedu.org docs h api http
and
there is an empty github repo with just
a license file in it
at influx db influx db dash r
so
you can be a hero to the r community
um
okay so creating a database
just do a post to slash db with the
username and password is as query
parameters it also supports uh basic
auth if you want to off that way instead
uh and you post json where you have a
name of a database and a replication
factor which says how many nodes in the
cluster each data point will be copied
to
if you can add users again it's a post
you post to slash db slash the name of
the database slash users
and then
the details are just name password and
whether or not they're an administrator
for the database
okay writing points
so again just a post slash db slash the
name
slash series
include the username and password
and essentially it's just an array of
json objects where the object has three
keys name the name of the series
columns which is an array of strings
that represent the column names and the
thing is on every single post those
columns can be different i mean i don't
recommend having a lot of columns in a
single series but the point is
you can write some columns some of the
time and
not other times and then points which is
an array of arrays where the index of
the array inside matches up with the
index of the column name
and querying so
just do
a get to slash db slash database name
series
pass in username and password and pass
in q equals
some query string
so
this is one thing we wanted to do which
was to create uh like a sql kind of
query language it's not exactly sql but
it's
close to sql um
and the reason we did this is because
we've heard from a lot of people that
with particularly with user analytics
the product manager or people who really
aren't programmers will want to ask
questions about the about things
and the workflow is they have to go to a
programmer and say okay can you write
this mapreduce job or write this query
or whatever and output this data for me
but the truth is a lot of these people
actually know sql
so we wanted
an sql-like language that they could use
so that they could actually just get at
the data themselves if they wanted to so
kind of reduce that that time of
having a question and getting the answer
so here we're looking at
all the columns from the user events
time series for
the last four hours
and the data that gets returned is just
json and it looks like
the data that you post in it has
it's an array of objects where the
objects have a name columns and points
and the points by default are in time
descending order so you'll get the
newest first
so
here's another one uh
so we're saying count
basically in
i'll say it in english first
uh
in five minute intervals tell me how
many uh
user events there were in each state for
the last seven days so if you have a
particularly busy site that gets traffic
from all 50 states every five minutes
you'll expect seven days worth of data
where you have 50 points per 5 minute
mark
so select count state from the series
group by time so we added this like time
function you see it's like 5 m so you
can also specify
microseconds milliseconds
seconds minutes hours days
maybe years too months or
no days i think is the last one
um
okay
so
percentile this is just computing a
percentile on the fly so we're saying
give me
the 90th percentile of the values in
response times in 30 second intervals
for the last hour
uh then there's this other thing that
we're we're actually building this right
now so this is also vaporware right now
but
it's it'll be ready in like two weeks i
promise
um
so
uh it's called we're calling it
continuous queries and what one of the
use cases we have for this is doing down
sampling automatically so in this case
like here i'm doing that percentile
query again but instead of like issuing
this query and expecting a response back
immediately i'm saying feed whatever
that result is into
responsetimes.percentiles.90
and there are a couple of nice things
this
uh this enables so
let's say initially you start writing
all this data
and you're you're fine like you're you
don't really have that much traffic so
it's fine to compute percentiles on the
fly from all the raw data but then the
queries start slowing down so like okay
wait a second maybe i should actually do
this where i like optimize this like ha
being able to do it on the fly is nice
because then you don't have to
pre-compute every single percentile that
you want but then once you get to a
point where
you're bringing in enough data you can
you can do this but the other thing is
when you issue a continuous query you
can also say where time equals
zero right so you can just say
for the entire series from the beginning
of time calculate that and because it's
a continuous query
it'll just keep running after after it
gets to churning through all the old
data yeah
why it's continuous
yeah well it's continuous because yeah
because you say into another series
that's right so in this case
at every five minute mark it'll output
that data
uh you just do that through the http api
basically there's an end point where you
can say show me all the continuous
queries they're running and you can say
kill that one
uh so yeah basically like continuous
queries get run by the cluster in the
background so it's kind of like um
like with mapreduce jobs in hadoop right
like you just like issue a command and
it goes and it runs it with those it's
just like once unless you have a
recurring job but
um
so another thing that we want to use
continuous queries for is for real-time
processing or monitoring of data um now
percentile that's a function that we
built in but we are
going to add something so that people
can define their own
their own functions i'll talk a little
bit about that in a bit
uh so you can also
uh do regex matches against values so
you could say like select everything
from events where the email
is from
a gmail account and you can also do the
not
the not regex operator as well
but you can also
do regexes against the time series name
itself so in this case i have a
continuous query that i've constructed
where
i'm computing the 99th percentile
uh for
any series name that starts with stats.
so basically i know that like i'll feed
in my raw events data here where i don't
care about percentiles and mainly i just
care about counting things
and all my telemetry data where i care
about percentiles i'll just have a
standard where i say i the prefix is
stats
so that i can compute percentiles like
automatically
ahead of
time
you can merge time series together uh
which is helpful for for doing group
eyes and stuff like that
so for querying we have functions right
now there's
count min max mean
distinct which is good for counting
uniques uh median mode percentiles
derivative and standard deviation
uh you could do where clauses with and
or
not
equals and uh
i actually i also forgot to say like for
the values in the points you can have
uh integers floats booleans or strings
uh finally there's group by clauses
where you can group by time intervals
but you can also group by column values
and then there's also a method to
periodically delete raw data you don't
have to delete all of the raw data you
can just say for this for these series
delete anything that's older than
you know like two weeks or whatever just
do that like once a day clear out old
data to free up space
so there's a built-in ui it's very raw
right now
but essentially you can go and you can
execute a query it'll return the data
and table and it'll render a couple of
graphs for you or however many graphs
there are for the number of columns that
you have
ideally
other people would build dashboard
builders and other visualization tools
on top of this because it has a standard
api
so this was interesting somebody
actually uh
wrote a command line client for it
so uh
yeah somebody wrote a node library and
then somebody took that node library and
wrote this so it's basically like a sql
command line client so you can execute
queries from just from the shell
right now we have libraries for ruby
front end javascript node python php
we'll have a go one in a week or two and
a java one also probably within a week
or two
so this is
definitely the vaporware section these
are kind of like ideas so one of the
things i like is i as i'd like to get
feedback on on these ideas that we have
so
i mentioned custom functions um we want
people to be able to define custom
functions
to do either matching for like where's
or
the aggregate functions right so the way
we're thinking about doing that is
through
embedded lua like you have in redis
so you could just write a little lua
script and that would run
or a yarn-like interface where there's
like a protobuf protocol an api
and essentially like you can write your
code in whatever language you're happy
writing code in uh and then
just issue a command and this thing will
run it in the cluster for you
uh and that's also another thing we have
to figure out with like custom real time
queries
so
essentially like
define this custom logic and it'll feed
that data through so it's kind of like
um
like a pub sub system where
you where you don't have to deal with
like
deploying the code that you wrote and
monitoring the process and running it
and all this other stuff and basically
it'll just like any of the data that you
output from the thing will feed back
into the
is
database
yes will it be yeah well
yeah would either be i mean it is it it
probably has two things no yeah it would
be a continuous query where the target
is like the process that's running it
and then when you output data you could
output into
one or more time series or whatever
uh and finally having queries that
trigger um web hooks
so essentially if we pair that with
custom functions
you'll be able to do like monitoring and
anomaly detection and stuff like that
all within within the data store
so the status of the project it's like i
said it's very much in development right
now
use at your own risk we have not blessed
a build for production use yet uh it's
based off of work that we did at
airplane so airplane is essentially
running version three of its api right
now
this represents what what will be
version 4 of airplanes api so we're not
running it in production ourselves yet
but the thing is like this is all
written go and go using level db as the
data store the current version of
airplane is written and go using leveldb
as the datastore
uh
so we should be migrating it over in
january the goal is to have
production ready builds by the end of
the end of the year
go to influxfub.org if you want to see
it read docs the code's up on github
right now
um we we want to finalize the api in the
next month we're still waiting to hear
from more people about like potential
use cases and things they'd like to do
with it
clustered version in december and also
continuous queries
in december
we're also available to help you out
with either consulting or just hit us up
in the chat in irc or whatever or on the
mailing list
we want to help people who want to get
this set up and start messing around
with it
so we also need your help
uh so for an api like what would you
like to see
we need help writing client libraries uh
our for instance
uh visualization tools like i said the
the built-in data explorer is really
basic right now uh it's not where we're
putting our efforts we're putting our
efforts really on the storage engine
and the distributed stuff
so
and ideally you know comments and
feedback on the mailing list
also
spread the word tell other people about
it start or watch a project on github
tweet or blog about it
and participate in the discussions
so we're having a hack fest on monday
december 2nd at pivotal where we're
basically just going to like hack on
different projects with this we'll
either do like libraries
or we'll build like visualization tools
or whatever like data ingestion tools
uh you know just to mess around
so
open source software i i really think
lives and dies by its adoption and
popularity right the more people adopt
it the people are developing it or more
inclined to actually
you know contribute to it and other
people are inclined to actually pick it
up and use it
uh so i just wanted to run through like
a quick
like number thought experiment or
numbers game i'm more of a developer
than a mathematician so bear with me but
mongodb when i wrote these slides had 4
406 stars
that company when they raised the money
last was valued at 1.2 billion dollars
so i estimate that a star on github is
worth
about 272 000
so
help uh help us make the project popular
go
play around with it give us feedback on
the api build things on top of it and
use it
thank you
that's very nice do you have plans for
any windowed aggregations in the
database what do you what do you mean so
so you've got aggregates that work on
discrete uh subsets of time do you have
any plans for moving aggregates across
the time
so the question was do we have any plans
for building aggregates across time
windows yeah because we're bucketing
them into discrete time windows i
actually hadn't heard somebody request
that before uh
what's the common thing in time series
okay
yeah moving averages oh yeah yeah okay
nice uh
i want to talk to you more
after you may have volunteered
two questions
is it possible
the question was can you operate on more
than two series at a time or do a
correlation between two series
um
so we do have uh support for join but
it's not join on
column value it's joined on time
so it kind of tries to like if you're if
you're picking from multiple time series
it tries to
yeah to align them based on time uh so
that actually
that's working right now um
so
yeah yeah so but you were you thinking
more about like
joining based on some column value uh
yeah we probably could do that oh my
only concern on joining on a column
value would be
performance really because the whole
thing is optimized for for time
i guess the second question is
maybe you can talk a little bit about
how this is similar to different shoes
something like what stream based i'm not
familiar with the project stream base
i'll look it up
so the they're kind of
the time series are of individual values
have you thought about uh histograms
like accents of instagrams
so
what i what i want to do is i want to be
a
through the bucketing to accumulators
in the histogram and then have some
sampler kind of stow away the value of
the state of the histogram over time
and so it would be a number of buckets
for the counts
so the question was um
have we thought about creating time
series that are essentially histograms
over time
uh
i haven't
that's also a new one
off to market i guess like
but they have to be tied together right
into one unit right so they can just be
different you're independent then you
don't really know whether
yeah
right
yes
so yeah i guess
the way to do that would be through
custom continuous queries like custom
functions where you just output that as
like into a new time series where you
have different columns as those as those
different pockets
yeah i want to do the kind of
aggregation of the histograms and the
source and not in the process because
the number of events that come out to do
that
can be high so the histograms themselves
can be small so you want you just want
to throw away the rod you don't even
want to store the raw data to begin with
you just want to like dump it
um
yeah that's probably something we will
think about later and not not for the
initial version
uh yeah absolutely i mean so like
yeah
like in in regular like system like
devops metrics like people use statsd
for that which is essentially like throw
a ton of data at it drop most of it on
the floor and throw summarizations into
yeah
yeah
danny's actually mentioning something it
sounds a little interesting you have a
continuous query that essentially said
you essentially check the data
check the data
yeah there's no reason why we couldn't
do that
yeah there's actually no reason why we
couldn't do that to say like hey don't
actually store this data just pipe it
into this other thing
yeah query is cool actually
uh the question about i'm not sure how
to do
the custom functionality what happens
when you do
what kind of index
uh so the question was if you if you
count stuff on the fly and you group by
some other things
what kind of indexes are created so
they'd actually like
half different states what's that
right what what computational work is
done for for those kind of group eyes
yeah so right right now everything it's
a it's a column-oriented database
uh so
if you where everything is indexed by
time so if you have like
four different columns um
and you just group by like time plus
some other thing like uh if you're
counting um
uniques and you're grouping by
time and like the user id right um
it will actually run through all of
all of the data points for that time
for that
that whole time and like output it uh we
are probably going to support uh
secondary indexes so you can actually
say like index on time and this other
thing
which is useful for
like if you're writing
a bunch of like customer data and i keep
coming back to like this customer id
you're writing that in and you do a
query where you say like show me the the
numbers for this customer you'd want to
actually have essentially what would do
is it would create underlying data
storage is it would create a separate
time series for unique customer id
of
of that data
does that make sense
no like right now there's no there's no
indexing everything is just indexed by
time series so by time so when you issue
a query you run through you don't have
to run through all the data so if you
have if you have events where you have
like 30 different columns and you do a
query that only hits one column it
actually only goes through the raw data
for that single column whereas like in a
traditional like sql database
uh
the rows
base it's how the data is stored on disk
but the rows are all contiguous so if
you're doing aggregate functions
um
it's it's slow because you have to read
in all of the data regardless of the
fact that you don't care about the vast
majority of it so column oriented
databases are generally a lot faster for
aggregate functions specifically
yes i'm sorry i can't hear you sorry um
to just get like the difference between
uh today and yesterday or something
instead of grouping by is there an easy
way to make like judicial times
is
which is to be able
to
do to do like differences between
different
values
like different column values um and then
also
for
the derivative function defining like
where
i think yeah
the question is what kind of performance
do we get out of rights so we haven't
really released any benchmarks yet um
i mean we've done like a really naive
benchmark but the problem is like
we we haven't we haven't put it together
the clustering code and stuff like that
the
target
the target for stuff that you're
actually storing
is to be anywhere from
let's say like 10 to 30 000 writes a
second for stuff that's replicated
like three times uh i mean single node
performance right now if you batch the
writes together and the one thing is
like hp as an api like the json is
really slow and we know this which is
why like having a bot an efficient wire
protocol is is another thing that's on
the to-do list
but
i mean
with a time series with a single column
like we clocked it at
79 000 points a second that may or may
not change uh if it was like we did like
one column
five columns and ten columns it was like
79
30 something and like 26k a second
um
so
but that's all that is actually getting
stored to disk
uh so obviously if we did something like
with the continuous queries where you
don't actually
pipe it to disk like you just pipe it to
this thing and then that does something
then you'll get
much better performance and again
once we you
the the performance is highly variable
depending on
whether you're batching rights together
or not right like if you
take a thousand data points all in one
right you'll get a much better
performance out of it than if you're
writing point by point
question
no so the question was is each post like
one data point and the answer is no you
can post to
multiple time series and multiple points
per time series in a single request
the the wire protocol we're thinking of
at this point is um
would just be like tcp and protobufs
so that's
that's quite a bit faster because you
don't have the json parse overhead it
needs to be overhead
yeah
i thought i saw one
so the question is am i comparing that
something like kdb uh
no and i don't
really think i'm going to kdp as much so
we're actually not building this for
people in finance uh i talked to a
couple of people in finance while when
we were getting started on this and uh
i heard one of two things
uh one
no we won't use open source or if we do
we won't admit it
uh because we write all our own stuff
and i know that a lot of like i so i
worked at a fintech startup back in 2011
and
uh 70 of the people i interviewed who
had worked at a major bank before and
have done at least one project where
they built a time suite database from
scratch
uh so i do know this a lot of that and
then the other answer was
no because we only buy closed source
software that is extremely expensive so
that we can yell at the people who make
it
uh some variation of that so
uh really like our target unless
somebody in finance tells me they're
interested in using it then i will
change my mind but uh our target
initially is really just like
startups and other like companies who
want to build like custom analytics
systems startups just happen to be the
people who are most likely to like
work with a new like young project so uh
yeah
well in fairness it's the type of data
you're planning on storing it not
necessarily the business that's doing
the story and data yes that's true it's
it's the type of data not the business
that's true yeah like there's
the thing is if you yeah if you're if
you're writing a highly optimized system
for a very specific like trading system
then you know there's a lot of overhead
in this that if you wanted to do
interest on user traffic on your website
yeah it's just it's just not going to be
as performant as something that's
optimized for that specific job
okay so
we use leveldb as the data store that
might change to what this question uh i
don't know the way the code is
structured right now it's essentially
just an interface like there's a data
store interface
uh and there's like a level db there's a
single file that does all the level db
stuff and i like i don't remember how
much code it is right now probably a
thousand lines of code or something like
that
um so
we don't really have like if in about
two weeks or so we'll we'll have a more
expensive like benchmarking suite built
up where we can like spin up a cluster
in ec2 spin up a cluster in azure
do benchmarking on it either single node
or multi-node and have all sorts of
different scenarios we're not going to
bother swapping it out until we have
that in place because we need to know
like
what's good and what isn't um
so
i don't know uh i had lunch with the
toku tech guys today they have an open
source name that sounds kind of
interesting it's based on fractal trees
instead of a log structured merge tree
which is what level db is
um
i don't know somebody pointed me to
sophia today but
i read that and i saw something that was
scary which is basically like if you had
i was in the go library but so if you
had like this iterator open and you
didn't close it before you close the
database like it would corrupt it which
sounds totally insane to me i'll have to
look into that
i'm open to suggestions
the question one said i read the paper
by the guy who wrote graphite about
architectural design decisions in open
source things
right
no i haven't but i will uh
we can't take the same data model as
graphite because they use around robin
database
we can't do because of the fact that we
allow people to store strings
so the question is uh since we're
focusing on the distributed stuff am i
worried that we're gonna have to write
all the same stuff that cassandra had to
write
uh
to
to deal with that in addition to writing
like the down sampling stuff and all
that other all that other stuff um so
v1 of the airplane api was actually
written in scala using cassandra as the
underlying data store that's the second
time i've used cassandra as a time
series datastore um
the problem
with that at least for us when we were
like we wanted to compute aggregates on
the fly is that you're going to do that
you have to pipe all the data over the
network because it's cassandra
so
we wanted something we want well there
were two reasons we went with an
embedded database
essentially which is what level db is um
that was one which was we wanted to be
able to run computations where the data
lives without piping it over the network
so we do things faster
and the second one really was at the
time when we were working on it for
airplane we wanted to be able to do
behind the firewall deployments
uh like private deployments and the
thing is like
having having cassandra as a requirement
like saying like oh we can give you a
behind the firewall deployment but
you're gonna have to set up these three
or four web services and run this
cassandra cluster good luck
yeah i know uh so
we
we wanted it to be easier to use um
so yes we do have to write quite a bit
of that stuff uh but not all of it right
so we use we don't use paxos we're using
raft which is another distributed
consensus protocol uh we didn't have to
write that code somebody else did
it's a great thing about open source
uh there are definitely some things we
have to write the the other thing though
about
us between us and cassandra is
we don't have to worry about as many
crazy scenarios as cassandra does right
like we can take a lot of shortcuts that
you would never take in a real regular
database
uh because
this data like this kind of data is
fairly unique it's almost always append
only or you're doing like a big bulk
load of historical data you're never
like updating it like you're just
writing the data and then you're
deleting it at some point if you need to
free up space and that makes it very
unique because they're like you can open
up some design constraints that a
regular database has to have
a title that you you
see that you were careful to put down
the the columnar the titles were just to
a value
plural does it actually do it's just a
value or a set of values in the column
do you read and write entitlements
uh
so when you read and write data can you
have a set of values in a single column
well no
the entitlement you're allowed to only
write to this particular column with
this value your security excuse me i
mean it seemed like your security was to
a value
not necessarily a set of things
oh oh yeah actually we were thinking
about it as so the question was with the
security i mentioned that you could only
write to
uh you could limit the rights so that
you would have to be like this column
with this value um the idea
the idea there was that um
you could write to any other columns
the restriction would just be that
you have to write that column with that
value so but your question is could you
make it so that you could write any of a
set of values right uh
there's no reason we couldn't do that i
mean
the harder part is the the other part of
just having the security in place to
begin with so
i don't see any reason why we couldn't
um
yeah
this set of clients or this set of
regions it's potentially which has
groups
yeah
yeah
okay it's good it's a good idea
nice
all right any other any others
all right thanks everybody